we're here with the beautiful inside and
out vanessa hutchins
okay
girl talk yes
um
so the last time you came on the show
you gave me some dating advice
i was you know i'm single i'm still
single um and uh
and i like being single so i'm not very
like eager and active yeah that's like
my best friend it's like kids work
friends yeah
lo you're full alone time is a huge
priority for me and then it's fifth
that's why gayle king is like you're
that's why you're single
because it's your fifth priority
but you told me
that if i did notice someone
that maybe i should slip into their dms
it's the thing ever everybody does it
um so
i really i know that slipping into the
dms is the term and i i honestly like
because you motivated me i figured out
even how to do it uh-huh so i dm'd a guy
okay
hot love that thank you for of course
giving me advice well i mean you're drew
barrymore any man would be lucky
thank you
well
thank you for saying that um
now um
you were just in rihanna's um savage x
fenty show
and you lo holy
cow
that's art that's me
that's art
the herringbone
the body the cross straps the lighting i
felt like i was probably swinging my
arms too much that's what i took away
from that photo but other than that i
was so excited i had always like grown
up watching like the victoria secret
runway shows you know and i was like oh
that's so cool and empowering and they
just look so fierce like i would love to
do that one day but then again i'm 5'3
so that was never gonna happen to me um
and then brianna asked if i would be in
her show and i was just like
a of course she's an icon but b like
what she stands for is so inclusive she
celebrates women of all shapes and sizes
and colors and to be a part of that is
just so it's dope it's an honor that was
just so hot and you can see the savage x
fenty show on amazon prime every year
that it comes out it is like a knockout
hit people love it i love it i love it
i'm so excited to watch it well it's a
show yeah it's not it's a production
it's insane it's like a carnival a
festival it's art it is um well speaking
of that's a perfect parlay into
halloween
which is
i hear it's your favorite holiday and i
heard you're a regular holiday
it's my favorite holiday in the world
let's watch us turn into five-year-olds
i know but it's true because it's the
holiday with no baggage gosh for bid you
don't have to get presents you can be
the freak you are you can be with
whoever you want to be with now you have
had some really incredible costumes over
the years can we take a look at just a
few sure all right here we go black
widow
i know it's amazing see that's what i
love full tilt commitment yeah
all right and next we have um catwoman
oh my gosh and then we can't forget
about darla because she's the bat girl
[Applause]
you could be her too
like i want to be do it i'll send you
the link i'm going to put on that outfit
and dm somebody
do as vanessa died
i actually had my first face time with
my boyfriend while i was in a spider
woman costume
because me and my best friend were
filming a thing and we had our spider
woman costumes that she had made for us
were fanatics about halloween and
dressing up and i was texting him and i
was like i'm in this really cute fit
right now i feel like we should maybe
have our first space time
i think he's pretty happy about it it is
great it was a great moment very
memorable how is he by the way great
he's adorable yeah
yeah he's like a foot taller than me
it's great
he took me to a sunflower field because
he knows i love sunflowers
it's nice to be with a guy who actually
listens and is very kind and you're so
deserving of that thank you you really
so where are you
thank you yeah well again fifth priority
um
because my number one priority is my
kids and um i can tell you what we're
going to be doing we're going to be
watching your new netflix movie called
my little pony a new generation yes i
cannot wait for this tell me about it
what are we in store for um i'm so
excited about it because i mean end of
the day like my little pony has been
around for like almost 40 years and like
the legacy is all about friendship and
and spreading love and joy and this
movie really sticks to that theme but it
is the new generation and i feel like
it's very reflective of where we are in
society um the unicorns the pegasi and
the earth ponies have been all separated
they don't know each other they have
these preconceived ideas of each other
and it's really driven by by fear
but it's about that it's about finding
your own sparkle celebrating the things
that make you unique the messages are so
strong and powerful but like just
wonderfully bite-sized for children to
take in all right well we have a clip
let's take a look
what are you doing you don't smell
thanks wait what i was told all you
earth ponies smell like rotten sardines
but you
do not
what else do unicorns say about earth
ponies oh just that you're lazy and not
the brightest crystals in the flores
charming nope just those three
well
vanessa
thank you thank you thank you so much
always the best seeing you it's always
the best seeing you do as vanessa does
i cannot wait to watch you in the savage
ex fenty show on amazon prime i cannot
wait to watch you in the netflix my
little pony a new generation um with the
girls and i just i've loved you then i
love you now i love you forever vanessa
[Applause]
[Music]
you